and again, it's a promise problem.
This time, the promise is that there exists some n bits string s for which the function f
works as you see right here,
where the output is given
by the binary dot product of the input with this string s,
and the goal is simply
to find the string s. So we can imagine that the
string s is hidden in some sense,
but we can learn about it
by making queries to f, and our goal is to find
this hidden string.
To be clear, most functions
won't satisfy this promise, but as usual, we only care about the
input functions that do.
As it turns out, the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit actually solves this problem
right out of the box.
If we run it for a
function like we have here that satisfies the
promise for some string s, the measurements will reveal the string s
with no post-processing required.
So let's see how this works.
We've already analyzed
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, so we can actually just
skip right to the end.
Here's the expression that we
had from before for the state just prior to the measurements, and that expression was
valid for any function f.
And now, if we substitute
in what we're promised about the function f and simplify,
we get the minus state
for the bottom qubit tensored with cat s for the top n qubits.
And so we get s when we measure.
There is some work to do to perform the simplifications
that I've shown here, and I won't go through that in this video,
but there is more detail about it in the textbook content for this series, which you can find by following the link in the description of the video,
or just try it for
yourself for some practice.
So what we found is that
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit solves the Bernstein-Vazirani
problem with a single query.
It's not too hard to show
that any classical algorithm, whether it's deterministic
or probabilistic, needs at least n queries
to solve the Bernstein-Vazirani problem for the simple reason that we need n bits of
information to recover s,
and each query gives us at
most 1 bit of information.
So we get another advantage of quantum over classical
query algorithms, one query for quantum algorithms,
n queries for classical algorithms.
It's worth taking just a moment to speak about the
nomenclature that's used in the context of this problem and a little bit about the history.
People sometimes refer to the algorithm that I just described as being the Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, but it's really just the
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit,
and that's something that was,
in fact, very clearly stated in Bernstein and Vazirani's work.
So it is a little bit strange that it's called the
Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm because it's pretty much the same thing as the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
minus the post-processing. Bernstein and Vazirani did,
however, go a step further.
They defined a recursive
version of this problem, where you basically
have to solve instances of the Bernstein-Vazirani problem
to unlock new instances of the problem that are arranged in a
complicated tree-like pattern.
It's a highly contrived problem, but the point is that by
defining a problem in this way, they could effectively stretch out
the one versus n query separation between quantum and classical.
And what they obtained is
the very first known example of a so-called super polynomial advantage of quantum over probabilistic algorithms.
This recursive version of the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem also turned out much later
to be very interesting in computational complexity
theory for different reasons.
Anyway, the point is that
Bernstein and Vazirani certainly deserve recognition for their important contributions,
but it really doesn't make
sense to refer to this as the Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, it's basically just the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll take a look at one
more quantum query algorithm known as Simon's algorithm.
You'll see a clear similarity
between this algorithm and the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, but it is different, and more importantly,
it reveals a much stronger advantage of quantum over classical
query algorithms.
Specifically, it gives us a
provable exponential advantage of quantum over classical algorithms, even probabilistic ones.
The problem it solves is a bit artificial, and it's hard to imagine a situation in which solving this
problem would be useful,
but it did directly inspire
Peter Shor's discovery of a quantum algorithm
for integer factorization,
and that very strongly supports
this idea of the query model as a Petri dish in which quantum algorithmic
ideas can be developed.
Let's start with the query problem that Simon's algorithm solves, which, as you might have guessed,
is called Simon's problem.
Here's a statement of the problem, and we're going to need to unpack it to understand what it's all about.
The first thing to
notice is that this time, the input function f maps n
bits strings to m bits strings
where m is some positive integer that isn't equal to one in general.